and then eventually obviously
uh
twitch came out of justin tv yep
twitch exactly so we had justin tv
started off as us trying to make our own
show
the show
was not good
to
put it kindly and then
luckily we opened up as a platform
anyone could broadcast and eventually
people were like hey we want to
broadcast games and it became twitch
and uh
the rest is history
it does say something about when you're
an entrepreneur the ability to pivot or
just
as you're building stuff and you're
being of action
and listening to customers that
sometimes some you'll just fall into a
gold mine or a diamond mine i mean it's
basically what happened you had no idea
that video games would be the concept
here you were making a modern day truman
show
yeah we drove drove the clown car into
the diamond mine
that's as the saying goes that's the
famous for people who don't know that
reference zuckerberg once said twitter
was like a clown car that
drove into a gold mine or something and
it was
so cruel but in some ways so accurate
and so on brand for zuckerberg
because it is true they started people
forget
odio was the original idea that evan
williams was working on
and he wanted to build a platform for
podcasting in the earliest days of
podcasting like again 14 years ago
before anyone who was podcasting was
nobody knew what podcasting was and
nobody
wanted to do it basically people voted
stupid it was like you want to do a
radio show why don't you just like
what's the point of that just do a radio
show
um
and then famously
i think evan said we need to come up
with something here
and i guess jack was working on just
updating your status just what are you
doing right now so the idea was
i believe inspired by the yacht remember
yahoo messenger had like you could pick
your status
yeah i'm out and aol aim had that too
you came out to
status bar and then put a message on it
right you could be like sleeping or
in a minute or whatever and so it's just
to update your thing but they too
stumbled into it it says something about
entrepreneurship i'm trying to think of
a company
that didn't stumble into their eventual
business model
uber went from
black town cars to ride sharing and then
food
airbnb they were doing something else
too what was their original business
they were trying to
they had another i forgot what their
original business is but they had a
different business and they were trying
to make money to survive and work on
their business so they decided to rent
out their apartment like their matches
on the floor department for design
conference that was in sf
to like generate income so they could
pay the rent
now just think about that you're so
desperate to make your rent that you
come up with a business idea that then
becomes arguably
one of the five best ideas of the last
two decades in silicon valley i think so
oh yeah
that's
that was incredible that's incredible it
just proves if you have the right
people who are like highly motivated
and relatively smart
and they're and
and stink of desperation then they're
gonna figure it out if they you give
them enough time you know you're gonna
figure something out
and there's like enough time and then
there's sometimes too much time if you
have too much money you've probably seen
this
company's got like infinite amounts of
money there's no pressure to
make the diamond right
yeah you gotta exactly you have to
that's the problem with all the people
who are successful and try again like
you know yours truly where you know you
have a little too much resources and
there's not enough desperation you have
to have like that ticking time bomb of
like how much money is in the bank
that's
a sub one year you know to keep you
motivated
i think founders do their best work
somewhere between 12 and 24 months so
i'm agreeing with you if it's over 24
months they're just like they put the
infinity symbol for their runway like we
have infinite and i'm just like
okay
but there is something about that 12 to
18 month window because
fundraising is a in a normal market what
three to six months so you have 12
months that means you got to get some
[ __ ] done for six months and then
you got to clear a market with investors
again and they're going to want to see
some progress
yeah you have a
clear window to figure it out if you
don't figure it out in this time then
you're clearly going to be dead so you
got it you got to do something
and when you look at the companies
you've invested in um what what common
traits do you see in
the people who figure it out in a major
way
not like get to a couple of million in
revenue but the ones who get to tens to
hundreds of millions of revenue is there
something you can think about with those
founders
that was unique in some way because we
get this all the time right like when
new investors ask us like how do you
pick founders
and there's so many different types like
if you look at the airbnb finders
they're designers right they were
you know not developers and then you
have people who are hardcore developers
you got people who are hardcore business
operations people it can be different
archetypes but do you see some trends or
behavior patterns i'm wondering in the
early days yeah i think it's like it's
those people who you're like you say
your technical background or whatever it
doesn't matter to people who are like
business people are successful
engineers are successful
but the attitude that i look for that i
think is like it's the people who are
both
humble enough to know that they don't
know most things and they are always
learning from people around them and
always trying to iterate their process
but then they're also confident enough
to keep going
for potentially ever so it's kind of
like that right in the middle of like
there there's there's a humility healthy
dose of like low ego community and then
there's a but there's a deep well of
confidence that's like i'm gonna figure
it out they have you know sometimes that
comes from some chip on their shoulder
or whatever they have some
insane drive but like there's some
things there's it's a combo of those two
things
like the best founders i know
yeah they're always like learning from
people around like i remember watching
like drew from dropbox or ryan from
airbnb and they would always have like
new mentors or new people they were
learning from who were like a couple
steps ahead of them you know
you do see that a lot the the people who
seem to be incredibly successful are
sponges for information they seek out
knowledge
they ask really great questions they
listen deeply they take notes they're
just rabid about that and but there's a
humility to it which is hey there were
people who figured this out before me i
might as well ask them
and then there's this
sort of resiliency and you get the sense
that somebody like travis or alex from
calm
you know they're just never going to
give up you know vlad from robin hood
you know just starting from our
portfolio you just get this like it's
like inevitable they're going to be
successful in their lives they're just
not going to give up
no matter what happens no matter how
hard it gets even if they run out of
money they're still going to show up for
work and figure it out you know as
opposed to a lot of the people
i thought were strong i invested in and
they're like
they hit a bump and you're like well if
you just cut
your 12-person team down to seven you
would add this much runway you'd have
more time to figure it out i literally
had one of them say i just don't want to
do that i'd rather just wrap it all up
and close the company
i was like okay well
thanks you just told me you're bluffing
you don't have it
i don't need to invest in your company
ever again like literally
you don't have the ability to just cut
five people to keep the dream alive well
then this isn't a dream
yeah yeah i mean i think there's a lot
of people talking about you know when we
started off people weren't coming here
necessarily to get
super rich it was like they were coming
because
they were interested in technology they
want to try to try something new they
wanted to be an entrepreneur because
they couldn't get a job anywhere else
you know like yes it was and then over
the course of silicon valley becoming
very successful and very very common job
path in the last 15 years you attract
people who are like high functioning
people who could be getting paid a lot
in
you know wall street or on facebook or
maybe they came from those places and
then they want to start a startup but
they're not they don't necessarily have
the same um tolerance for pain
uh that's something that you know that
that other people
do when they like have no choice or
they're like a misfit they're just like
this is like the only shot i have you
know
micro acquire is a startup acquisition
marketplace that cuts out the middleman
basically that means they help startups
get acquired efficiently if you're a
founder looking to sell microacquire is
free private and involves no middlemen
you know how it is you try to get a deal
going there's somebody in the middle
they don't care about the parties
involved in some cases they just want to
close a deal and you really have to
wonder who are they working for right
you're always wondering about incentives
there well you don't have to worry about
incentives at micro acquire to date
micro acquire has helped hundreds of
startups get acquired and they
facilitated hundreds of millions in
closed deal volume their platform
includes over a hundred thousand buyers
including me i'm paying for the service
it's pretty great there are thousands of
startups currently listed for sale and
hundreds of successful acquisitions have
occurred so far founders get free and
instant access to over 100 000 trusted
buyers while staying totally anonymous
on the other side of the marketplace
buyers like me simply play 290 a year
for access to deals on the platform
which means
you're getting rid of the look you lose
right unless you're serious about this
you're not going to pay the 290 so
microacquire help startups find buyers
it's as simple as that they'll help you
start conversations that can lead to an
acquisition in just 30 days for free
just go to try.microacquire.com
twist once again try.microacquire.com
twist